obviously it was used to justify the
continuation of lockdowns far beyond
what was necessary it's being used today
to keep schools closed you know you have
the education unions
saying that even after they're
vaccinated if there are any cases of
community spread
for that if there's even one case of
community spread in a two-week period
they will not go back to school so i
mean this is a recipe for keeping
schools closed forever
you had our district attorney in san
francisco
used covetously excuse to empty out all
the jails you had
gavin newsom use covetous excuse for
billions of dollars of no-bid contracts
to his political supporters
and so you know you have this suspending
of normal operating procedure
of the way that government works and if
we're going to suspend it every time
there's a
like one covet case well that that's not
going to work
so let's let's shift a little to to lock
downs and generally what's happened in
the last year because basically the from
almost the day we're posting this it was
pretty much a year ago right now two
weeks to flatten the curve
now it's a year later and people you
know biden's double masking and
you know california you still can't go
to indoor restaurants or go to the gym
and i guess we're gonna
partially open on april 1st or something
like that
um but so much of this does seem
attached to big tech because they're
letting you say certain things about
lockdowns and
not letting you say certain things is
your belief that there was just no
science behind the lockdowns at all
at any point well i guess at the very
beginning of covid
we didn't exactly know and so i don't
fault anyone too much for the decisions
that were made to lock down
back in march or april um we we simply
didn't know
as you'll recall i mean we were seeing
what was happening in italy the
hospitals were completely overrun
and so this idea of you know of of
locking things down to buy time
so that our medical system didn't get
overrun i could understand the argument
but
i think by this by last summer it was
becoming pretty clear
that lockdowns had an enormous cost to
them
and a very unclear benefit
and and i think as the year progressed
we had more and more data around this
um certainly i think by the fall
um anyone who is paying attention to
that data would have
you know should have been against uh
lockdowns i think
even by may i was tweeting that the
right policy was to go all in on mass
and and to not do lockdowns so
i mean i think the data was clear even
by then
so what do you think was going on i mean
like in the mind
we'll get to california more
specifically but generally like the ma
in the mind of gavin newsom in the mind
of
of gretchen whitmer in the mind of
andrew cuomo these people that
you know in essence destroyed their
states in a lot of ways
versus texas and scary florida
like what do you think they were
thinking because i can't find any
science anywhere
i get what you're saying yeah for a
couple weeks you could try it and there
was this unsure moment and all that but
then after that
yeah i mean i don't know exactly
why they thought the political calculus
it would benefit them to have this
extreme lockdown policy but i but i
think there was sort of a collective
failure of elite thinking
on covet and really on many other issues
and it really you know you have to go
back
to the who getting just about everything
wrong
from the beginning first um you know all
the way back in january saying that it
wasn't clear that there was human to
human contact
and then when it was clear that there
was they
um they greatly exaggerated the uh case
fatality rate by claiming that there
there weren't
a lot of asymptomatic cases um you know
we
would later learn that there was a huge
number of asymptomatic cases and
therefore we should
you know the infection fatality rate was
more like one-tenth the
the case fatality rate but they got that
wrong and sort of miseducated us and
then that
led to us thinking the the virus would
be even more severe than it was
um you know then then they were wrong
about mass
and so was you know vouching the cdc i
mean i wrote a blog post in early april
saying that mass should be the the
policy i thought that was um
that was the type of thing that was low
cost high benefit
um and the type of thing we should be
doing you know not not lockdowns um
and then you know they got lockdowns
wrong and then they reverse course on
that
and so there's just been like
systematically
i think the health establishment just
seems like they've gotten everything
wrong here
and it kind of i mean just to tie it
back to the censorship thing
um it shows how ridiculous it is
to maintain this position that we can
censor
based on what experts tell us as youtube
has been doing
you know youtube has been censoring
uh coveted uh videos that have been put
up that they say
uh contradict the who apparently without
irony because no one has contradicted
who
more than the who itself yeah um
so but but this idea that we can simply
rely on experts i think that
i mean it has to be that the that has to
be one of the big takeaways of covet is
that
we we cannot rely on these experts
they're just wrong way too often
and even you know fouchy today and what
when the guidance we're getting today
is far too conservative you know um
fauci recently said that we might have
to wear mass until
2022. well why i mean
you know are you saying the vaccines
don't work um
because it seems to me that that the
messaging we're getting now is
effectively anti-vaxx
i mean if the vaccines work right
they've all become anti-vaxxers yeah
yeah if the vaccines work and biden has
now said that every american adult can
get one by the end of may
why would we need any more restrictions
after memorial day
um and so i was in favor of a mass
policy early on but i do not
support uh having a mass policy once
vaccines are available why
so you guys were just talking about
zeroism on on the show
and that it's a perfect segue for that
so can you explain that
yeah so jonathan chait actually came up
with it um
you know i think he's a writer for the i
guess
new yorker or i always forget if it's a
new yorker or new york magazine
i think it's a magazine okay yeah i
don't think i think um
i think he's probably uh uh i don't i
don't think he's red pill i think he's
he's pretty liberal but
um he might have called me racist once
or twice in a tweet
okay well he wrote one good call where
he uh coins this term uh zeroism and
what it basically is
is a refusal to deal with covid
according to cost-benefit analysis and
to insist
that even one case of covid is
unacceptable because
somebody can die and therefore we need
to have a policy of stamping out
every last case of that that's zero-ism
um the problem with zeroism is
that we're we're never gonna get rid of
it i mean there are always gonna be a
smattering of cases somewhere
it's a seasonal illness it's gonna
return and
the problem is that if every time it
returns we
now have the justification for the
politicians to
you know engage in like all these
emergency measures it gives them
extraordinary powers um so
yeah that that that's the thing i think
needs to be be challenged i mean and
look look at how zeroism is being used
right now or has already i mean
obviously it was used to justify
uh the continuation of lockdowns far
beyond what was necessary
it's being used today to keep schools
closed
you know you have the education unions
saying that
even after they're vaccinated if there
are any cases of community spread
for that there's even one case of
community spread in a two-week period
they will not go back to school so i
mean this is a recipe for keeping
schools closed forever
you had our district attorney in san
francisco
use covetous excuse to empty out all the
jails you had
gavin newsom use covetous excuse for
billions of dollars of no-bid contracts
to his political supporters
and so you know you have this suspending
of normal operating procedure
of the way that government works and if
we're going to suspend it every time
there's a
like one covet case well that that's not
going to work
are you worried though that that is the
net effect of this thing that they
pushed us for a year and they whoever
they are but
you know in effect the system so boy we
can really get people to destroy their
own lives
and not see their family and not travel
and yet they'll do it in some places
like florida but we can get people in
california to act like sheep and there's
almost no pushback so so why not keep
pushing
well i think there's there's a lot of
pushback now i mean look i think there
are a lot of people
who who are frightened of covet and
there will be some
ptsd about it but i think that you know
we're seeing now with the newsome recall
that i think people are very upset
about the restrictions and the the
the hypocrisy of it you know the fact
that newsom was
going to french laundry and you know
even during
the time when he was doubling down on
lockdowns and telling people they
couldn't go to the beach
which i mean that makes no sense because
there
there's been no real outdoor spread um
so you had that you know he was sending
his own kids to private school when you
know the public schools were still
closed and still are closed
um so i think people are pretty riled up
by this and i do expect
that people will want to go back
to the way things were pre-coveted very
very quickly
um and i i but i think the battle to be
joined over the next few months is the
battle against zeroism
and um and i and i and i i expect that
we'll win that battle
um i expect that if newsom sticks to the
zeroest position
he will he will be defeated i mean the
recall election will be
in i think around august i think every
american who wants a vaccine will be
able to get one
in may and so i think
to the extent that california still has
all these restrictions
i think every week pressure is going to
build people in california look and say
well wait
none of these other states are doing
this stuff why are we still
restricted if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell